♪ Je suis malade ♪
C'est bon,
je suis plus malade.
Tu vois, quand tu as la crève, et que tu appelles
ton patron pour lui dire que tu viendras pas,
t'es un peu obligé d'en faire des tonnes
pour bien prouver que tu es malade.
Teuf ! Je suis malade.
Je vais pas pouvoir venir.
Je vais sûrement mourir. Teuf !
Bon, en même temps, c'est normal.
Tu vas pas faire
Allô ? Ouais, j'ai de la fièvre.
J'ai mal à la gorge,
je suis hyper malade.
On se voit la semaine prochaine.
En vrai, moi, le simple fait de savoir
que je ne vais pas aller travailler,
rien que ça, je me sens
un peu déjà mieux.
3 minutes après avoir annoncé
à ton patron que tu n'iras pas travailler...
En fait, c'est juste
la maladie : d'aller travailler.
Avant de consulter un médecin,
moi, je vais toujours checker
un peu ce que j'ai sur Doctissimo.
Mais ça sert à rien, ce genre de sites,
parce que, à chaque fois, quasiment,
le conseil du mec qui te répond,
c'est toujours :
Ah ben consulte ton médecin.
WTF ?
Limite, maintenant, les gens,
ils ne vont même plus chez le médecin.
Tu sais, ils font d'abord
confiance à ce genre de site.
Mais tout le monde !
Ben voilà, depuis quelques jours,
je me sens pas très bien. J'ai mal à la gorge.
Mmh-mmh, d'accord.
Donc "mal à la gorge".
Ben écoutez, le meilleur conseil
que je peux vous donner,
c'est "consultez un médecin".
Donc consulter un médecin.
Le plus rapidement possible.
Il y a beaucoup de gens qui se plaignent
en disant que les médecins écrivent mal.
Ben, parce qu'ils ont fait
de longues études.
Mais moi, perso, je préfère un médecin qui écrit mal,
parce qu'il a fait de longues études,
plutôt qu'un médecin
qui écrit comme ça :
un antibiotique par jour.
C'est C ou -QUE, je sais plus,
antibiotique ?
Parce que je me suis arrêté en CE1,
ça ne vous dérange pas ?
Ben écoutez, je vous conseille
de prendre ça.
À mon avis, ça marche.
Je suis pas sûr, mais je pense.
C'est marrant, parce que le médecin,
c'est le seul être vivant,
que tu connais pas, mais à qui
tu fais totalement confiance.
Tu vois, tu fais tout ce qu'il dit.
Faites aahhh !
Aahhh !
Allez maintenant,
toussez fort !
Teuf ! Aahhh !
D'accord. Maintenant,
continuez en tenant ce cintre.
Aahhh !
D'accord. Maintenant, mettez-vous
en slip, en faisant la brebis.
Mêêê ! Mêêê !
Ah, c'est bon, j'ai trouvé ce que vous avez !
Vous êtes complètement con !
Mêêê !
Mon médecin,
il est un peu chelou.
Tu sais, il parle en baragouinant.
On dirait qu'il est
vraiment saoulé, quoi.
Genre, on dirait vraiment
qu'il en a marre de répéter
la même chose,
à chaque fois, à chaque consultation.
Oh, c'est clairement une inflammation
de la gorge, à mon avis, une petite laryngite.
Vous prenez trois fois par jour
du Doliprane, ça va passer.
Des fois, je me demande s'il parle
toujours comme ça dans sa vie...
Chéri !
>> Mmh-mmh.
J'ai très, très envie
de te faire l'amour ce soir.
Oui, c'est clairement
une distraction à mon âge,
c'est un soin avec trois coïts
par jour entre les repas,
plus un Doliprane,
si t'as l'air maladive.
J'ai plus trop envie, en fait.
Je cache pas que je vais
peut-être me masturber.
J'aurais trop voulu être médecin.
Bon, déjà, pour être
comme le mec de Scrubs.
♪ Daddy was kung-fu fighting ♪
Et puis être médecin,
ça doit être génial.
Dès que t'as un problème, t'as pas besoin
d'aller voir le médecin. Tu peux t'auto-soigner.
Teuf ! Teuf !
Oh non, j'ai une bronchite
mixée à une laryngite.
Bon bah, deux comprimés d'Amoxil
par jour, plus un Doliprane.
Ça me fera 42 €. Ha ha !
C'est un peu cher, hein !
Moi, j'ai toujours rêvé
d'être médecin, juste pour,
au moins une fois dans ma vie,
pouvoir faire ça :
Oh Suzanne, je l'ai écrasé !
Poussez-vous, laissez-moi faire,
je suis médecin !
Non, je déconne, j'ai toujours rêvé
de dire ça un jour.
Bonne journée !
Oh oh !
Excellent !
C'est stylé, les métiers
comme ça,
où tu peux intervenir en cas d'urgence,
comme un héros.
C'est vrai qu'il n'y a pas de métier,
où, en cas d'urgence, tu ne sers vraiment à rien.
Je l'ai écrasé !
Ça va Monsieur ?
Laissez-moi faire, je suis boulanger.
Ah non, ça ne marche pas, là.
Désolé !
Moi, ça m'est déjà arrivé une fois
d'aller aux urgences, pour une urgence.
Mais en voyant un maximum
d'hémoglobine là-bas,
j'ai compris que mon urgence, en fait, était
quand même moins urgente que d'autres urgences.
Excuse-moi, monsieur, ça vous dérange pas,
je passe avant vous ?
J'ai vraiment mal,
j'ai mon chat qui vient de me griffer.
Ah ! Bon, bah allez-y, y a pas de souci.
>> Merci.
Ça peut attendre.
J'ai juste mal à la tête.
Vous êtes 4 millions
à avoir rejoint ma page Facebook !
C'est énormissime, merci à tous,
c'est vraiment cool !
Ça me fait trop plaisir !
N'hésite pas à rejoindre ma page,
comme ça, peut-être
qu'on sera 4000001.
Heu, je sais pas ce que t'as.
Mais si je peux te donner un petit conseil,
va voir un médecin.
Je joue mon spectacle
"Norman sur scène"
dans les Zénith de France,
à partir d'avril prochain.
Je joue à Amiens, à Rouen,
à Châlons-en-Champagne, à Metz,
enfin je crois,
et dans plein, plein d'autres villes.
Alors venez me voir en spectacle,
je suis vraiment hyper marrant, c'est abusé !
OK !
>> T'as un préservatif ?
Un préservatif ? Euh, je sais pas,
peut-être, attends, je vérifie.
Ah, bah, j'en ai 16
et un max de lubrifiant. Nickel !